if you're watching this intro on YouTube
today good luck
a prisoner named Jonathan Richardson who
now goes by the name Autumn cordeleone
wants to undergo
and wants it to be done at taxpayer
expense
such a demand would be outrageous enough
on its own
but it seems even more egregious when
one learns that this inmate is not in
the Clank for jaywalking or tax fraud
this inmate is in prison for murdering a
baby
the 41 year old Richardson murdered the
11 month old daughter of his girlfriend
in Evansville Indiana in 2001 according
to the Indiana Department of Correction
records
after the crime after a conviction after
incarceration Richardson continued to
show No Remorse remarking to Corrections
Officers all I know is I killed the
little effing b-i-t-c-h
Indiana Law currently bars the
Corrections Department from using
taxpayer money for
so the ACLU is suing to get the law
overturned
and this ideological matter unlike other
issues I've mentioned before that there
can be no conciliatory Middle Ground
either it's true or it isn't there's no
middle ground on a fundamental question
of human nature
but in this particular case about that
ideological matter I think we might be
able to come to a compromise
the ACLU wants to chop this unrepentant
baby murderers
the taxpayers do not want to chop this
unrepentant baby murderers
so what if we just chopped head off and
call it a day I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we've got a
really insightful interview from
Hungarian president Victor Orban Tucker
Carlson flew over there
as so many American conservatives make
the pilgrimage to Hungary these days
Orban has a really important lesson for
the West for America as we look ahead
potentially at World War III uh first
though I I want to turn back to our own
country and Washington I also want to
ask did any of that intro make it to
YouTube did any poorer poor producer
Danny must have had a field day with
that one trying to evade the YouTube
sensors but speaking of problems in the
head
Mitch McConnell
top Republican in the Senate has had
some health scares recently you remember
some weeks ago he was giving a press
conference and he just kind of froze up
and wasn't able to speak and just kind
of one couldn't tell if he was having a
Tia or a seizure but whatever it was he
did seize up he didn't he didn't say
anything I didn't even mention it at the
time because I thought look this is an
older man and sometimes people have
these Health incidents there's no use in
making a big news story about it
twice as a pattern though and so it's
just happened again Mitch McConnell was
speaking to a local Chamber of Commerce
and as he was asked a question he just
seemed to lose his ability to respond
my thoughts about what running for
re-election in 2026.
that's true
and then there you see
[Music]
this happened last time too hear the
question Senator running for reelection
in 2026. he stopped speaking of this
mouth tightened up his mouth tightened
up again here
all right I'm sorry you all we're gonna
need a minute it's kind of looking off
in the distance you see this poor
communications director is trying to
salvage this there's obviously all the
Press is here
another Aid comes to his side
I think not so much to speak to him is
to give the appearance of speaking to
him so it looks like there's a reason he
took a pause
then he comes out of it somebody else
have a question please speak up
and she you know it's kind of a
half-hearted attempt to to spin this to
say oh maybe the senator just couldn't
hear you please speak up but
no one's really buying it the press for
their part we're not we're not too cruel
about it this is rough stuff
I'm not one for
term limits I'm not one for age limits I
think we have both of those things
already in our country and it's called
an election and the people can make
their decisions if they want I think
Mitch McConnell for all of his flaws and
for all of his perhaps uh
philosophical or ideological ambiguity I
think he's a really effective wielder of
power and he
deserves as much credit As Trump I think
for overruling Roe v Wade because he
held the line so firm on the judges so I
I like cocaine Mitch you know I'm I'm
Pro cocaine Mitch and mostly because I
don't want him and his mob to just gun
me down with tommy guns but but
he's obviously approaching the end of
his career no question about it they're
going to be new calls for him to retire
I'm not one of the people making those
calls but it's going to happen he's
going to have to step down sooner or
later
the reason I mentioned the story has
nothing to do with him really it's much
more about the state of our country and
it ties back into Hungary when I was
over in Hungary
I was really impressed as are so many
American conservatives who go over there
because they've got basically a
conservative
country a conservative government a
mostly conservative culture conservative
public life at the anniversary of the
country on Saint Stephen's day they just
had a big giant Cross spinning in the
sky made out of lights and drones and
the the public culture
is a Christian one in America we have a
liberal public culture where we have
rainbow parades going down the street
and Weirdos and leather jackets smacking
each other around half naked and in
Hungary they have a Christian public
culture
in America privately people go to church
privately people live out normal
religion just like in Hungary people
privately do all sorts of weird things
that are probably not conducive to their
flourishing but it's the public the
political matter
there that we're really talking about
and one of the reasons that the Orban
government has been able to do that to
go from a country that was dominated by
Soviet Communists for 45 years to
probably the leading conservative
country of Europe the only conservative
country of Europe the way they did that
in part is because the government is
quite young the ministers the the
members of parliament they're relatively
quite young and vigorous and they've got
new ideas
that is going to happen in America
and the shift is going to be huge it's
going to be as dramatic maybe more
dramatic as as the sort of thing we saw
in Hungary
because the Boomers and the silent
generation which is the generation
before the Boomers they've just held on
for so long don't forget Bill Clinton
baby boomer president
uh George W bush baby boomer President
Barack Obama Gen X so we're moving ahead
in the generations but then Donald Trump
we go back
so we got our third baby boomer
president then Joe Biden we go back even
further we get a silent generation
president these guys have held on to
power for an abnormally long time
and
when that generational shift happens
it's not going to happen gradually it's
going to happen all at once because all
these guys are in their 80s and so it's
not going to be a slow decline it's
going to be they're all going to just
quit or die in office God forbid or just
be
pushed out
and what is that shift going to mean
it's not that the shift is going to be
left versus right necessarily it's going
to be generational the young leftists
the aocs have a different approach to
politics than the older leftists like
Dianne Feinstein or even Nancy Pelosi
the young conservatives this is where
this is especially pronounced the young
conservatives people like JD Vance
people like Josh Hawley
people like Ron DeSantis have a
different approach to politics and
conservatism a different political
philosophy than the Mitch McConnells and
the older Republicans and so when that
shift happens when it's the younger when
it's the JD Vance's who are now running
the Senate conservatism politics
generally is going to look a lot
different we've got one of those new
generational
new right type candidates who might be
running for office again first though
how's your health doing
now you might want to check out
metashare right now go to metashare.com
Michael as a daily wire listener you are
not just informed you're engaged and you
value freedom and personal
responsibility that's why we think you
will like metashare metashare is a
community-based approach to health care
that lines up with the principles you
believe in your values matter and with
Medishare your Healthcare dollars won't
be used for medical procedures that
don't line up with your beliefs
metashare is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record it's not
health insurance it's a community of 400
000 Believers committed to caring and
sharing with one another members save up
to fifty five zero percent or more on
their monthly health care costs for a
limited time daily wire listeners will
receive a 150 gift card when you join
Medishare to find out more go to
metashare.com Michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l that
is medishare.com Michael
terms and conditions apply so head on
over there right now
go to medishare.com Michael and get a
150 dollar gift card
one of the brightest young stars as far
as I'm concerned of the new right
generation who did not win his senate
seat last time is Blake Masters I really
like Blake Masters I think his head is
screwed on pretty pretty straight and it
was very sad that he lost his Senate
race and he might be running again
this according to a report in the Wall
Street Journal
uh Blake is considering entering the
race for Kirsten Cinemas seat and the
reason this is particularly interesting
is because
Carrie Lake who ran for governor last
time and lost she says the election was
stolen maybe it was who knows but either
way she's not the governor she seems to
be running for that seat as well so you
could have a feisty little race uh Carey
lake has tied herself very closely to
Trump like Masters has also tied himself
closely to Trump
what do I think about it I think great
the more the merrier I'm all for it I'm
very Pro primary I know that there are
acolytes of all sorts of candidates who
hate the idea of primaries especially in
the presidential race they say why
doesn't Trump just not run that mean old
Trump Trump he's not we don't want him
well you do want him the Republican
party wants him because he's currently
at 58 in the polls but or they'll say
why doesn't Ron DeSantis drop out why
not because it's a primary and people
run in primaries and these are tough
guys with thick skin and I like it
I like seeing these fights in politics
and I think Blake is a good candidate
I'm glad he's going to get in the race
the knock on Blake is that he's a loser
he lost his race
kind of like
George W bush he lost his first race for
Congress
uh Barack Obama he lost his first race
for congress a lot of very prominent
serious Statesmen on the right and on
the left
lost their first race or lost a crucial
race in their lives
Blake is a young guy he can be a
self-under he's made a lot of money
and he represents that that generational
shift I I am very much looking forward
to the day much as I love Ronald Reagan
and I do much as I love William F
Buckley Jr and I do I wrote the new
introduction to Bill Buckley's most
famous book got a man at Yale I love all
those guys but those guys are dead
they're dead they're in the dirt and we
shouldn't dig up their corpses and try
to zap them back to life like Dr
Frankenstein and and have them be the be
the bizarre uncanny zombies of
conservatism they dealt with the
problems of their time as best they
could now we're in our time and we have
a responsibility to deal with those
problems and politics involves Eternal
principles yes but it also involves
changing circumstances and applying
those Eternal principles to totally new
circumstances uh I'm I'm excited for the
day
when politicians will not just
reflexively
quote mindlessly recite the piffy
one-liners of
conservative leaders who have been dead
for 40 years
I'm excited for the day when we can
inject a little fresh blood and some
fresh ideas and at the very least some
fresh approaches to politics and
that day does appear to be approaching
rather rapidly
young people get this and Hungary gets
this Hungary gets this so uh prime
minister Urban sat down with Tucker and
this is the you know I love Tucker and
but I just I feel such Envy because I
was just over there for a few days and I
want to sit down to Victor Orban maybe
next time I go to too hungry I will be
able to do that uh but at the very least
we got this excellent excellent
interview from Tucker highly recommended
must watch in which Orban discusses not
just the Divide between the East and the
west or China and the west but a big
divide Within
the West
it's more about our civilization I mean
the Western Christian Civilization now
the main division line is not according
to ideologies it's a it's it's deeper it
has an anthropological character so on
one side in Europe and probably in your
country but in Europe definitely there
are groups of people
who think that the most important thing
of the word is their ego themselves me
this is the center of the world the
other
Camp of the people the other part of the
society saying that it's not true
because there are certain things which
are more important than me than my ego
family Nation God and because they are
more important than me I have to serve
this higher level of things so this
Society has a majority here in Hungary
and the other society which is
concentrating only me you know only
dealing with myself it's it's more
westernized dominating factor of the
political life
so insightful one thing I really admire
about Orban is he's a seriously
intelligent educated person who takes
knowledge and learning and wisdom very
seriously and I know that seems really
basic you would hope that all your
Statesmen would do that but they don't
they patently don't and the other thing
I like is he's not just some completely
disconnected intellectual in an ivory
Tower somewhere he's a Statesman he's a
guy in the Rough and Tumble of politics
but he takes these broad historical and
philosophical questions very seriously
and he can simplify it this is one of
the signs that that somebody knows what
he's talking about is when he can take a
complex matter like this anthropological
divide within western civilization and
distill it down in really simple terms
here's the Divide people who think that
I mean my is the most important thing on
earth and people who think that there
are more important things than me
simple enough and it's so true
I think even if you caught the
Western liberals and liberal leaning
so-called conservatives if you caught
them in a moment of Candor maybe you got
them after a couple of drinks they would
admit this they would be proud of this
they would say yes of course I exist to
fulfill myself I'm interested not in
caring for my family and community and
Country I'm interested in self-love I
need self-care you know it's just I'm
gonna I'm gonna take care of me now
there's a Kim Kardashian said this after
her divorce she said in my 40s I'm
finally gonna I'm gonna take care of
myself
as though she'd she was Mother Teresa
before that but now she's going to take
care of herself and it's not just the
left it's the right it's the right under
the influence of
people like Ein Rand the right under the
influence of a hyper individualism the
right under the influence of
libertarianism which says
yeah me I mean my greed is good I'm just
going to pursue my own interests you
leave me alone you can't tell me what to
do I'm entitled to do whatever I want
that's my freedom that's my Liberty
that's not the classical Western
understanding of Liberty that's not the
Christian understanding of Liberty but
it is the modern liberal conception it's
exactly what prime minister Orban is
talking about and he says look that's a
view he's he's obviously criticizing it
but he's more just describing it he's
saying that is the dominant view in the
West
but we have a different view which is
much as I want to pursue my own
individual interests much as I like
myself much as I have certain desires I
recognize some things are more important
namely
family
country and God
family is the basic political community
man going back is a big distinction
between liberalism classical modern and
otherwise and
the classical Christian tradition
liberalism says
the basic unit of society is the
individual
Christianity and Aristotle and classical
understandings of politics say that the
basic unit of society is the family and
it's the family because politics is
public so it involves other people says
that man is a political creature The
Social Animal okay
big difference so Orban says starts with
the family and then goes to love of
country and the importance of nation
right because that's an extension of the
family it's an extension of the kins
folk and the tribe and and your
patriotism is an extension filial piety
and ultimately what this is what this is
ordered toward is God
because some things are good and true
and beautiful and we should want to seek
for those and some things are
destructive and ugly and false and not
conducive to our flourishing and we
should avoid those and
the name for truth
for truth himself is God it's Jesus and
the name for the highest good the sumum
bonum in to use an older Latin phrase is
God
so that's what we're going to orient all
of our political efforts toward really
basic stuff and
or Orban I really like he's so
clear-eyed about this he's really humble
about it because he'll say look we're a
country of 10 million people we're not
going to lead anything we're not we're
not going to be the dominant hegemonic
power ever we don't we're landlocked are
you kidding me
but because of the unique circumstances
of Hungary it's got this weird language
that nobody speaks it's a pretty
coherent people the country is 1100
years old we've been able to preserve
this thing and maybe we could look and
learn some lessons because
there's one statistic that shows you
how these ideas are playing out in
society
every single country in the west is
dying is literally dying not having
enough people to replace themselves and
the birth rates generally continue to
plummet one country has started to turn
the birth rate problem around
coincidentally it's the one that says I
mean my is not the top priority
family country and God is pretty simple
stuff I'm not saying it's easy to
implement but it's pretty simple now
when you want to start making a family
you're probably going to want a bed for
that and you ought to check out Helix
head on over to helixsleep.com
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep that is why you need to
check out Helix mattress Helix has
harnessed years of extensive mattress
expertise to bring their customers a
truly elevated sleep experience they
just launched their new Helix Elite
collection which includes six different
mattress models each tailored for
specific sleep positions and firmness
preferences I've had my Helix for years
I absolutely love it night after night I
sleep like a sweet little child like
like an angel okay
Helix has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else get
out of my mattress I'm a married man go
to helixsleep.com Knowles take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners hurry on over to Helix
sleep.com slash Knowles with Helix
better sleep starts now
folks it's almost here the new 10 part
original series with Candace convicting
a murderer is coming to daily wire plus
next week very excited about this series
you'll see the shocking amount of
evidence that was omitted in making a
murderer don't take my word for it watch
the series yourself draw your own
conclusions here's the trailer
collect calls from uh in May
inmates until DNA evidence cleared his
name the two rivers man was convicted of
sexual assault in 1985 but exonerated
with DNA evidence in 2003. so this is
the infamous Avery lot now two years
later he again finds himself tied to a
police investigation accused of
murdering Teresa halbat on the Avery
property Steven Avery's 16 year old
nephew admitted his involvement in the
rape and murder of Teresa halbuck the
car is discovered just around the bend
it was just this worldwide phenomenon I
think they framed this guy I think he
intended to crush the vehicle but ran
out of time Avery thinks the 36 million
dollar lawsuit he filed is why he's
being targeted in this investigation
[Music]
Netflix made millions of dollars from
making a murderer but the filmmakers
left out very important details
mountains of evidence that you have not
yet seen the blood vial the most
egregious manipulation from the movie
interrogations that's when he started
beating me because I told him that he's
sick cell phones and I saw melted
plastic parts of a cell phone interviews
her arms were pinned behind her head
they made Steven Avery look like a
victim you believe your brother is
guilty
I don't know if I'm a suspect I've been
on high
sick and tired of media deception
evidence piling off why would they omit
so many different things why are you
editing my testimony
I am not going to make the same mistake
that the filmmakers did
rearranging the testimonies the to lead
a portion of it at the end how could
they claim to care about the truth they
all know that Steven Avery committed
this crime
what is your emergency
the evidence forces me to conclude that
you are the most dangerous individual
ever to set foot in this courtroom
daily wire viewers get exclusive Early
Access on September 7th to view episodes
one and two of convicting a murderer the
series makes its official debut on X
once known as Twitter on September 8th
at 9 Eastern Candace will also be
hosting a live event on X at 5 PM
Eastern with some special guests stay
tuned for that the full series will only
be available on dail bear plus so go to
dailywire.com subscribe to get access to
watch the full series as new episodes
are released every Thursday for a
limited time you get 25 off with code
truth so take advantage of that before
the offer runs out on September 7th code
Truth for 25 off your subscription daily
wire plus.com slash subscribe
you want to see proof of this
problem
that we only think about individuals and
ourselves and we don't think about the
family and the nation and broader groups
we don't think of ourselves as a people
anymore we just think of ourselves as
individuals
New York City
is going to be broadcasting public
Muslim prayers throughout the day
with very few restrictions
previously there were some restrictions
on the loudspeakers blaring the Muslim
prayers in New York now Eric Adams
taking those restrictions largely away
according to the new rules
says the mayor
mosques will not need a special permit
to publicly broadcast the Islamic call
to prayer the adhan on Fridays and at
sundown during Ramadan
for too long he says there's been a
feeling that our communities were not
allowed to amplify their calls to prayer
today we're cutting the red tape
and saying clearly that mosques and
houses of worship are free to amplify
their call to prayer on wet Fridays and
during Ramadan
without a permit
and Muslim New Yorkers will not live in
the shadows of the American dream
while I'm mayor of the city of New York
okay
I like Muslims I like Muslims
I
especially in our modern culture that
has gone completely liberal and atheist
and off the rails I feel that in many
ways
I have a lot more in common with Muslims
who at least recognize that God exists
and we owe him some worship and we ought
to orient our lives around something
other than just the hedonistic pursuit
of pleasure and material Goods I I get
it so I'm really not knocking Muslims
here in any way but
is New York now a Muslim City
I'm a New Yorker I was raised in New
York
born in New York is I don't remember
being a Muslim City
not that long ago it was a Christian
City it was an explicitly Christian City
the most beautiful cathedral in America
is in New York St Patrick's Cathedral
about a bazillion parishes all
throughout New York lots of
devout Catholic immigrants over time the
Irish the Italians Hispanics now
in 1956 on Easter there's a famous
picture of those those three gigantic
skyscrapers in New York where they
arranged their lights in their Windows
to be in the sign of a cross so you had
the three crosses just igon Mount
Calvary
but now I guess it's a Muslim City now
what Eric Adams would say what the
Liberals will say is no it's just a city
for everybody just everybody you can do
whatever you want you can have a
Christian prayer I mean we don't have
something like the call to prayer on the
loudspeakers but you know you could have
church bells maybe and we could have the
the Muslim call to prayer the adhan
through the loudspeakers and we could I
don't know whatever the Jews want to do
they can do that too everybody can just
do everything well
how how can they if let's say there's a
church and a mosque right next to each
other
and they both want to broadcast they are
loud prayers
at the same time
you can't do it both at once that's just
going to be cacophonous that's going to
be incoherent
so you're gonna have to have some either
permitting process or you're gonna have
to prioritize one over the other
not to say that Muslims can't practice
their religion not to say that we're
going to persecute anybody of any
religion but
when
mutually contradictory ideas and
practices come into conflict you can't
simultaneously exalt both of them that
would be a violation of Aristotle's law
of non-contradiction
we've known about this one for a long
time
Millennia we seem to have forgotten it
though
politics has to have a certain character
inevitably it will because public life
is not infinite we're limited by time
we're limited by space we're limited by
the airwaves you can only broadcast one
thing across one medium at one time
so we need to agree upon a public
character for things and in recent
decades we've totally knocked that out
America was founded as a Christian
Nation it grew as a Christian Nation or
civilization's been Christian for two
thousand years and then all of a sudden
about half a century ago we just one day
pretended that it's not
and so we said no you can't this is a
con it's a secular country it's a
secular Civilization now people still
want there to be a Christmas tree in the
Public Square people because people are
still normal even if they don't talk
normal they at least behave usually in a
kind of normal way at least the ordinary
run-of-the-mill every day people maybe
not the intellectual Geniuses who run
our society off the rails so they still
want those things people still want a
nativity scene in the Public Square but
the way that the courts have Justified
this in recent years is to say oh well
these are actually secular so they're
okay a Christmas tree it's not a
Christian symbol it's a secular symbol
it's part of our culture even the crash
the nativity scene the baby Jesus in a
manger in a way it's kind of secular
they say
they justify it on its on its secularity
I don't want it to be justified I'm
being secular it's not it's deeply
religious and the reason people want it
is because we're a Christian country
and that means that when Christianity
comes into conflict with other belief
systems
Christianity needs to get pride of place
it needs to get precedence
it means that when people are arguing
over what goes in the the Public Square
the Christmas tree or a statue of a
demon called Baphomet which actually was
put inside a public government building
not that long ago we say nah no no
demons sorry
if you want to worship demons go out in
the middle of the night with witches in
the woods you we're not even going to
really stop you from doing that but
not in public no we don't do that
if the Muslims want to have a call for
prayer at some special time I'm not even
totally opposed to some version of that
but they're going to have to be some
restrictions on that so as not to
completely upend the public character of
our country which has existed for over
200 years in our civilization for two
thousand we need to start thinking I
know this is going to be a naughty word
for conservatives and you're
some of the libertarian types are not
going to want to hear it it's the c word
and you're not allowed to say the c word
we're going to need to think
collectively
not like communists
not where you break everything down to
its basic part and build it back up in
this weird heinous amalgam like like
like Dr Frankenstein but
like a culture
like a people with a common good like a
country those are the other c words that
that impel one to think a little more
collectively
a lot of individuals does not a country
make a country is made up of families
and communities with culture and rituals
and habits and beliefs that Define the
whole place
and sometimes when we have individual
desires that that are not conducive to
our own flourishing or the flourishing
of society sometimes we've got a give
those a back seat
and do the things that are good for
everybody in all the individuals
included now speaking of religion and
public life CNN is very upset CNN is
furious
because
Uganda has just arrested a child rapist
and CNN is furious about that
they don't that's bad because this is
what the headline says
two Ugandan men
May face death penalty
after quote aggravated homosexuality
charge
two men in Uganda
are facing separate charges of
aggravated homosexuality and offense
punishable by death under the country's
controversial new anti-gay laws these
are anti-gay laws now what I love about
Twitter under Elon Musk X now
is these these reader notes the little
reader added context notes
in this case on the CNN tweet it says
one man is accused of having a sexual
relation with a disabled man the other
of a sexual act with a 12 year old child
both are charged with aggravated
homosexuality to find as same-sex
relations with someone who is HIV
positive a child an elderly person or
disabled okay
before getting into the Weeds on what
that means
we're talking about two cases here one
of which involves a child rapist
and the the headline in the first line
in the CNN article says this is this is
an example of the country's new anti-gay
laws
I thought the LGBT movement just spent
40 years trying to convince everybody
that LGBT activism has nothing to do
with grooming little kids
right there was they always had kind of
a reputation that what they did involved
little kids and then they spent 40 Years
of marches and political campaigns and
willing race and all the rest of it
saying it has nothing to do with little
kids and then they've spent the last
three or four years focusing on little
kids specifically little kids in schools
bringing gay porn into elementary
schools and now CNN CNN in print lumping
in pederasty with homosexuality and
saying that heterasty is implying that
pederasty is an intrinsic part of
homosexuality and if you outlaw
pederasty your your law constitutes an
anti-gay piece of legislation
uh this phrase aggravated homosexuality
it refers to a few different things
including uh sex with same-sex people
who are disabled or elderly or otherwise
incapacitated and they're going to be
people in the west who say well that's
crazy you know we wouldn't have a law
like that that's insane okay first of
all
Uganda is a different culture than our
culture
Uganda we used to have laws that were
not so open about doing all sorts of
weird sex stuff but Uganda still has
those laws and you might say well I
don't agree with those laws okay you
don't live in Uganda so I don't know why
it's so much of your concern
unless you are a dedicated liberal who
wants to impose liberalism around the
entire world
because we've got three things coming
into conflict here
in the in the controversy over Uganda
one is the really creepy approach of
Democrats to little kids and sex that's
obviously the most obvious part but
putting that aside
we got three things coming into conflict
liberalism which says everyone should be
able to do whatever weird sex stuff they
want all the time no matter what the
communities think no matter what the
cultures think no matter what the
religion thinks or the state things
the next one is democracy
I promise you the majority of ugandans
are not in favor of pederasty or any
other kind of weird sex stuff
so here you've got liberalism and
democracy at odds we're always talk
we're talking about liberal democracy
and we use the two interchangeably
they're totally at odds here and
self-determination who determines the
laws in Uganda the ugandans
or CNN and Elite liberals in America who
gets to determine it listen the coherent
liberals the consistent ones are going
to say we do
ugandans don't have any right to run
their own country we determine that
because they're wrong and we're right
okay that's one view it's an imperialist
View
but fair enough it's a liberal
imperialist view so not that's not great
but okay but at least one has to
recognize
the rank hypocrisy of the constant
babbling about our democracy we have to
preserve democracy from the evil fascist
anti-democracy people and then out of
the very next breath
they say we need to destroy democracy in
Uganda we need to destroy democracy in
Hungary they don't like Orban obviously
we need to destroy democracy and or they
didn't like it when Italy elected
Maloney we need to destroy a democracy
in
any number of places to contradict
liberalism my favorite comment yesterday
is from Elaine m5184 who says mini
Michael also has a Saint Michael
protectus patch on his backpack you
really can't make this up yes uh the the
young man the 12 year old boy who stood
up to his teacher and whose mother stood
up to the teacher
and refused to take off his Gadsden flag
from his backpack after these ridiculous
Educators said it was a pro-slavery
patch or some ignorant nonsense uh that
boy some have pointed out that he and I
have a little bit of resemblance
I want to State it for the record people
seem confused
that boy is not
to the best of my knowledge my son
so why is wise child who knows his own
father listen life you know people do
all sorts of weird things and we lose
memories and but I don't
I'm very confident that boy is not my
son but I'm extremely proud of him maybe
he's like a sort of spiritual child you
know and he did in addition to the
Gadsden flag which is fine he also had a
Saint Michael patch very very cool very
conservative that boy has a bright
future
ahead of him
now speaking of foreigners
speaking of foreigners actually before I
move on from the Uganda thing there's
one line I got it the attorney Justine
Balia who's representing one of the guys
in the Ugandan aggravated homosexuality
cases tell CNN quote of course the fact
that the law is being enforced in this
way is entirely unconstitutional because
it seeks to criminalize what is often
consensual conduct between adults
often consensual conduct Hold Up Wait
what you're you're saying look this law
this law is awful and terrible and
unconstitutional because it
like sometimes the cut the conduct is
consensual excuse me that's your best
defense okay not not a very good defense
but moving on speaking of foreigners
Corrine Jean-Pierre at the White House
has said that Joe Biden has stopped the
flow of foreigners illegal aliens into
the United States
Eric Adams the New York mayor is saying
about these migrants uh in New York City
any plan that does not include stopping
the flow at the border is a failed plan
so why aren't you guys stopping the flow
at the border we are stopping the flow
at the border if anything the what the
president has been able to do on his own
without the help of republicans in
Congress something that he had to do on
his own again because Republicans refuse
to give the funding necessary to deal
with a situation a broken immigration
system that has been broken for decades
they produce what they choose to do is
play politics but the person the
president has put a plan that is indeed
the data showing is that it is indeed uh
stopping slowing down the flow of
unlawful migration and that is because
of the work that this President
continues to do without without the help
of Republicans
what Corrine Jean Pierre just said is
not true but there is a little tiny
kernel of Truth there
and this is this is this thing that the
Liberals always do
here's how it's not true
since May there have been about 3 600
illegal aliens crossing our Southern
border
illegally obviously every single day
that does not sound like a stopped flow
of migration sounds like historic highs
I think the exact number we're down to
now is about 3
360. that's where they're obviously
there's significant fluctuation
now the reason there's a little tiny
kernel of Truth in what you're saying is
back in March the number was 7100 so
there was this huge insane surge
in set 30 30 3360 is an insane surge too
but this is double that 7 100.
and then they got it down a little bit
so what Kareem Jean-Pierre can say is oh
yeah we're stopping the flow
we were at 7 100 a day
so we're talking millions and millions
and millions of illegal aliens pouring
across per year and now it's down to
only over three thousand I remember just
a few years ago when we got up to 2000
that was historic shocking crisis
but now they're saying thirty three
hundred sixty oh that's pretty good
that's stopping the flow and this is
what the Liberals always do this is how
they gain power they take a lot and they
give back a little bit
they take a lot and then they say okay
we're gonna we're gonna kill babies up
until the moment of birth and then okay
we'll put some restrictions in the third
trimester maybe in some places probably
not even that oh good see we're winning
conservatives see look the Liberals are
moderating they're compromising
hey we're going to everybody
down to kindergarten okay maybe just
Middle School oh good we're winning
we're fighting back in the culture what
are you talking about
we started here you started on the
50-yard line liberals took this thing
all the way down to the end zone and
then we go back to what the five yard
line 10 yard line okay well look we're
winning we're not winning we're getting
crushed we're getting destroyed
but because they are so bold in their
aggression which conservatives almost
never are we're we're always negotiating
with ourselves
we're all we always listen to the the
squishes and the libs and the
establishment types who say well we
can't really we can't try to ban
abortion you know that's not where the
that's not where the voters are you know
oh yeah you think the voters were for
the kids no they weren't the Democrats
just took it and then they seeded a
little bit of territory back and then
that was The New Normal
well I don't I don't know this is such a
just tactically it's such a stupid
tactic
anybody if you've ever engaged in a job
negotiation
or any kind of negotiation you know
never negotiate against yourself
always ask for the most
extreme thing that you could plausibly
get
and then allow your negotiation partner
to pair you back a little bit
that's what the liberals do that's not
what we do
we negotiate with ourselves and we lose
speaking of regression
John Mellencamp
just got into trouble you're the
musician John Mellencamp he
was on a Bill Maher's show
and he made an outrageous claim he said
black people are not better off today
than they were 200 years ago the playing
fields are a lot better than the cotton
fields that's what I would say about
that maybe I'm crazy John but it seems
like making no money as a slave picking
cotton was it was not as good as playing
left field for the Yankees I mean I'm
sure they were uh you know reasons why I
mean Dave Winfield has some notes
against Steinberg
there is one or two percent of black
people in America who have a better life
oh stop that's what you think one or two
percent okay let's say ten percent it's
still a number out of my ass it is hot
that's where it belongs hey I just
pulled a number on my ass I know but I'm
telling you that's that's just not true
but you know well okay well I I mean
that's to listen we do have statistics
talk you might talk talk to my son
he'll tell you well he saw one very
horrific incident maybe that has colored
his thinking what do you think that's
the only incident that happens of course
not so I know you're going to look at
this and you're gonna say Bill Maher is
being the more reasonable one here
because John Mellencamp he's referring
to some incident of some black guy got
beat up or something and he's saying see
this is proof that the KKK runs around
the country and this is America's as bad
as it was under slavery or whatever and
Bill Maher says no I don't think so you
know I think actually playing left field
for the Yankees is probably I'm not
saying it's perfect but it's probably a
little better than you know working the
cotton fields but
in a way I think I'm more on
Mellencamp's side here when he says
black people are not better off than
they were 200 years ago at least let's
say 150 years ago
so we don't have great statistics From
Slavery but after slavery we start to
get some relatively better numbers on
it's true that
black people get a higher wage than they
did when they didn't have a wage
but here's just one crucial
statistic marriage rates collapsed
so there was very little legal marriage
among slaves under under slavery
Tennessee actually I think allowed a
loud marriage with between slaves but it
was very hard obviously because if a
slave gets sold down the river then
there goes the family the family's
broken up it's just absolutely horrific
so after slavery though you get legal
marriage and black people got married at
much higher rates and they got divorced
at much lower rates and they had
families in a much more stable way today
that has collapsed
that alone means black people are not
better off than they were 150 years ago
that'll just that one statistic and you
see it among so many other areas of
society
but just that one statistic would do it
see well they're better off because they
have more money
maybe yeah maybe that maybe they have
more money
but money isn't everything money isn't
money is fine to have I'm not opposed to
it but it's not even the primary thing
and our society has duped itself into
thinking that that's all that matters
that's that's why we've embraced
globalism and liberalism and materialism
is because we think that ticking up the
GDP is all that matters the Liberals
have thought that and the conservatives
have thought that and so we say well who
cares if you lose your borders and your
culture and your national identity and
your religion and who cares about that
we're getting more cheap crap from China
and we we have more trade and look at
how the cost of certain Goods has come
down
some cases it's actually spiked up
because inflation's going crazy because
our economy is totally out of whack but
yeah okay also look at how our life
expectancy is going down because people
are killing themselves and oding on
drugs look at how birth rates have
collapsed because people aren't getting
married and they are getting divorced
and they are using contraception and
they are killing their children through
abortion and they're doing all these
sorts of things
that mean that we are not we we fool
ourselves in in a liberal Society we say
oh we're so much better off because we
have iPhones
we are worse off today by almost every
measure than we were 100 years ago we
have better dental care I guess that's
true I'm not saying we're worse off in
every measure
but if your Society is literally dying
and if the building block of society is
collapsing and has actually been defined
into nothingness in recent years you
cannot say with a straight face that
you're any better off than you were 100
years ago in fact you are much worse off
okay speaking of spiritual matters today
is theology Thursday and we've gone
through
we had a Protestant
we had a Catholic
we had a Jew
now we're going to have
a little bit of a mixture of all of
those things we're going to have a a
Messianic Jew on Dr Golan roshi for
theology Thursday the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code Knowles Canada
wlas at checkout for two months free on
all annual plans
[Music]